usual is a major component in oil of
clothes
it has a molar mass of 164 point 2 grams
per mole and is seventy three point one
four percent carbon and seven point
three seven percent hydrogen the
remainder is oxygen what are the
empirical and molecular formulas for
eugenol and just as a refresher
empirical formula is the simplest ratio
of the atoms in the molecule and we'll
see that in a second and the molecular
formula is the actual number of atoms in
the molecule so see if we can figure
this out so the first piece of
information they gave us is that we have
that the molar mass of 160 of eugenol is
164 0.2 grams per mole so just to
simplify things on our head let's just
assume let's just assume that we have
one one mole one mole of eugenol eugenol
and just as a bit of a refresher a mole
is just a huge number
it's like saying we have a million
molecules of eugenol but a mole is just
an even bigger number and we know that
the molar mass of you know if we have
that many molecules of eugenol then
since we have one mole we know that that
is going to have a mass of 164 0.2 grams
so another way to say it is we have 164
0.2 grams of eugenol eugenol now they
gave us the composition they tell us
what percentage is carbon what's
hydrogen and then the remainder is
oxygen so if we assume we have a mole of
eugenol and so and they we know that
that mole will have a mass of 164 point
2 grams we can just use a percentage the
percentages to figure out what is our
mass of carbon hydrogen and oxygen so
let's figure this out so if we have
let's start off with this so 164 0.2
grams of eugenol times times let me do
it in another color
times seventy three point one four
percent this will tell us how much what
is our mass of carbon that we're dealing
with so let me let's figure this out so
our mass of carbon get the calculator up
up here
all right so we have one hundred sixty
four point two times so seventy three
point one four percent is the same thing
as point seven three one four point
seven three one four so we have a
hundred twenty one hundred and twenty
point one let's go with that that's we
have four significant digits each of
these number so let's just go with 120
points of carbon so this is one hundred
and twenty point one grams grams of
carbon now let's do the same thing for
the hydrogen of the oxygen so we have
one hundred and sixty four point two
grams of eugenol times what percent at
which our percent composition of
hydrogen is right here seven point three
seven percent so times seven point three
seven percent what is this going to be
equal to get the calculator out so we
have one hundred sixty four point two
times seven point three seven percent is
point zero seven three seven and we will
get twelve point one so we have twelve
point one grams of carbon twelve point
one grams of carbon and now they don't
give us explicitly the percent
composition of oxygen but they're we
could figure it out fairly recently
because we know everything leftover is
oxygen so we could take the mass of
carbon the mass of hydrogen oh sorry
this isn't mass this isn't grams of
carbon that's grams of hydrogen we could
take the mass of hydrogen the mass of
carbon so subtract them both from 164
point two and whatever is leftover will
be oxygen so let's do it that way or we
could figure out the percentage this
oxygen because these all have to add up
to 100% and then multiply either way
would work so let's do that so we have
the whole if we have one mole of eugenol
it's one hundred sixty four point two
grams we just figured out that we have
that one hundred and twenty point one of
those grams are carbon and that twelve
point one of those grams twelve point
one of those grams are hydrogen so
what's left over we have thirty-two
exactly thirty
two grams of oxygen so what's left over
when you subtract these two guys out
I'll do that in a in a in green we are
left with 32 grams of oxygen so if you
have a mole of eugenol it's 106 it has a
mass of 164 point 2 grams and if you
break it down by the masses of the
Constituent molecules 120 grams of
carbon 12 grams of hydrogen 32 grams of
oxygen now what we need to do is figure
out how many moles of carbon this is how
many moles of hydrogen this is and how
many moles of oxygen and this is maybe
something that you should have memorized
at some point because these are the
three most common elements you'll ever
deal with but just as a refresher you
could look up on any periodic table for
carbon for a carbon you would see in a
periodic table the atomic you could eat
well most periodic tables will give you
the atomic weight which is the weighted
average of the different isotopes of
carbon around but in general the atomic
weight or the weighted average of the
atomic masses of the different isotopes
but carbon you should just remember that
the atomic weight is pretty close to 12
to 12 atomic mass unit which means that
carbon has a molar mass so carbon has a
molar mass of 12 grams per mole or if
you have a mole of carbon molecules it
will have a mass of 12 grams we do the
same thing for the hydrogen of the
oxygen hydrogen has if you whether you
take a single isotope or you take the
weighted average it's atomic weight or
mass depending which one you use is
pretty darn close to 1 and so hydrogen's
molar mass is 1 gram per mole there are
some decimals here if you look it up on
a periodic table but I just remember
carbon is 12 hydrogen is 1 and then
finally oxygen is 16 so oxygens is
approximately 16 atomic mass units its
atomic I guess if you take a specific
isotope atomic mass if you take its
weighted average atomic weight and that
means that its molar mass is 16
m's sixteen grams per mole now we have
the number of grams of oxygen hydrogen
and oxygen so now we should be able to
use this information down here to figure
out how many moles this is how many
moles this is so let's do this so we
have it's 12 grams per mole but we want
to divide by grams because we want this
gram to disappear in the numerator so
what we could do is if it's 12 grams per
mole that's the same thing as one mole
one mole for every 12 grams for every 12
grams all I did is I took the reciprocal
of this right here if we have 12 grams
for every mole that's also true that we
have one mole for every 12 grams and the
grams cancel out and we are left with
120 point 1 divided by 12 which is
pretty close to 10 pretty close to 10 so
this is this is equal to 10 moles 10
moles of carbon so we know how many
moles of carbon we have in one mole of
eugenol now let's do the hydrogen so we
did some multiplication here and so here
we have one mole of hydrogen if we take
the inverse of this or the reciprocal of
this has has a mass of 1 gram so really
this is just going to multiply out so we
literally have we could say 12.1 moles
of hydrogen but because we're looking
for formulas we should that's pretty
darn close to 12 so we should just say
12 moles of hydrogen and then finally we
have our oxygen our oxygen and we have
one mole of oxygen for every 16 grams
for every 16 grams of oxygen 32 divided
by say the grams cancel out of course 32
divided by 16 is 2 so this is equal to 2
two moles of oxygen so if we have one
mole of eugenol we have 10 moles of
carbon 12 moles of hydrogen and 2 moles
of oxygen so we just we now have the
ratio or you could even think of if we
have one molecule of eugenol we would
have 10 carbons 10 carbons we have 12
hydrogen's we have 12
hydrogen's and we have two oxygens and
we have two oxygens and we're done this
is the molecular formula we have for
every mole or we could think of it in
moles which is a huge number or you can
think of for every molecule of eugenol
we have 10 molecules of carbon 12
molecules of hydrogen 6 molecules of
oxygen
this right here is molecular formula
molecular molecular or molecular formula
and the empirical formula is essentially
taking this ratio into the simplest
terms and all of these have a common
factor of 2 so the empirical formula
empirical formula we essentially just
put this ratio in simplest terms so we
can divide all of them by 2 so let's
divide all of them by 2 and you have 5
carbons for every for every 6 hydrogen's
for every 4 oh sorry this is an oh six
this is two oxygens let me make that
clear let me make that clear erase a lot
of stuff to get there there you go that
was 2 oxygens don't want to make that
blunder we saw we have two moles of
oxygen two moles of oxygen so this is
the molecular formula molecular formula
formula and the empirical formula
empirical at least the two is still
divisible by two so you divide all of
these by 2 you get the simplest ratio
for every 5 carbons you have 6 you have
6 hydrogen's and you have and you have 1
oxygen or you can put it 1 right there
if you like and we're done